[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
host for the evening a man who has no
obvious connection to sci-fi or tech in
any way a man who flunked every science
class a man who once brought his iPhone
to the Apple Store to get it fixed only
to realize it wasn't turned on
he clearly has no business being here
but we love him anyway Sir Patrick
Stewart
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening and thank you so much
ladies and gentlemen I cannot tell you
with what pride I send here before you
and how honored I am by being invited to
be your host for this evening Awards the
SciTech Awards I just mentioned that in
case you weren't sure you were right
Awards now while I know some of you may
be fans of films I have been in they
could not have had the impact some did
without the innovative work of many
people here tonight
you are the film scientists the film
magicians your innovations open new
doors and give the creative community
new opportunities for storytelling
personally I am in awe of all of you
you turn equations and code into
fantastic visions showing us worlds of
pure imagination and in this room
tonight we have some of the best and the
brightest minds in our business
now we have a big night ahead of us as
we hand out nine awards and 36 honoring
remarkable individuals so let's begin
shall we
when audiences see a digital character
moving on-screen they might think it's a
simple matter of drawing a picture one
frame at a time but just as humans
require bones joints muscles digital
characters need something under the skin
that keeps them all together allowing
the animator a way to make them walk and
talk and this is what's called a rig
a digital puppet and the process of
creating rigs can be labor-intensive
rigging began as a manual effort with
one artist creating one rig at a time
but these days films could demand
hundreds of digital characters with ever
increasing complexity but as always big
challenges force new innovations and
this is where our first two groups of
scitech recipients take center stage in
2002 the film The Chronicles of Narnia
The Lion the Witch and the Wardrobe
posted a help-wanted ad hundreds of
digital character rigs needed for
immediate work apply within to visual
effects Studios jumped at the chance to
take this challenge head-on so let's
learn a little about our first award of
the evening block party
[Applause]
The Chronicles of Narnia had massive
numbers of digital characters and each
would need a unique rig one of the
systems that arose from that need is
block party from Industrial Light and
Magic there were multiple versions of
character rigs going around I 11 the
thought was you know what if we can take
those complex units like an arm or a
spine and just make it this packaged
thing that can plug into the block next
to it and then create a character rig
that way the secret to block parties
automated and fast rig building is in
the title
it's literally like building with blocks
each block is a little piece of a rig
with a purpose like an arm or shoulder
so blocks are essentially mini rigs and
those little rigs piece themselves
together with lots of other different
blocks creating motion for the character
multiple blocks can be connected to
create a character and the blocks are
swappable so even after a full rig is
assembled if the artist wants a
different spine they can simply replace
it with another spine block moreover
once a complete rig is constructed it
can quickly repurpose for a different
character simply by fitting the original
rig to the new character our main goal
with my party really was to help make
the job of the rigger much simpler so
that they don't have to think about
those technical complexities every
second of every day while they're doing
their rigging block parties rigs can be
stored away for future use and since its
inception more than twenty four thousand
unique rigs have been created for almost
100 feature films many of which have
been nominated or received the Academy
Award for visual effects including
Pirates of the Caribbean Dead Man's
Chest Bloc Party has contributed to at
least one Oscar nominated film every
year since its birth as well as the
recent blockbusters Kong Skull Island
star wars the last Jedi and Thor
Ragnarok it's really really cool to be
able to support these artists who are
extreme perfectionist and
they do and make it possible to bring
bigger and better and more innovative
characters to the screen
tonight the Academy presents a technical
achievement award to Jason Smith Jeff
white Rachel Marie Rose and Michael
Justin lead Utah for their work
for their work on ILM block party come
on up to the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
so as many can attest the developing
developing technology for our industry
is often driven by pure passion for us
Bloc Party really epitomizes that
passion so thank you to the Academy for
honoring us and this technology that we
really love I'd also like to thank my
parents Carol and Dan for their endless
support over the years and to my husband
Justin and to my beautiful children
Clara and Damon thank you for standing
by my side through this journey and
finally to any young woman who may be
watching this and dreaming about her
future career I am proof that you can
[Music]
thank you cheers to those who strive for
creative solutions to complex problems
for example my epic wife Michal is nine
months pregnant our first child is due
tomorrow
but she said you got to go accept your
award well you better get on that last
plane to San Francisco tonight before I
have this baby we call your you're
insane I love you and thank you for all
the support
I'm also immensely grateful for my
parents cherylin are through ten who are
here tonight
thank you for your endless encouragement
to live a life filled with passion from
the career inspiring t1000 in Terminator
2 to Jon double Steen's talent amazing
talent visible in every bone in block
party we salute ILM s world-class
creature artists we'd also like to just
say a quick thank you to carry Phillips
in ILM for being the kind